>>Dr. Susan Kleiner: I walked into this building,
it's like the good mood building; colors and
it's so g-o-o-d.
[laughs] Google, right.
So it is great to be here, I'm thrilled to
be on the Google campus in my backyard and
it's just so nice to know that your whole
programming here is starting to center around
health and fitness.
At lunch we were talking about that it's time
to take a stand, that if we don't have health
we don't have the fundamental tools to progress,
to proceed, and certainly to excel.
So health is critically important.
What I have learned in the years of being
a sports nutritionist is that health is great
but we have very important performance goals
that we also want to accomplish.
Wouldn't it be great if those could overlap?
And most people really want to be happy, that's
what everybody wants.
What was interesting to me when I said to
you, "How do you feel?" is that there was,
you know, like one or two who said "good,"
I heard happy, but everybody else was kind
of quiet.
And you know it's very interesting when I
go into an elementary school and I ask the
kids, "Tell me how do you feel?" they right
away can tell me, "I feel happy, I have ants
in my pants, I have too much energy, I'm sleepy,"
they yell it out with no inhibition at all.
I go to a middle school and I say, "How do
you feel?" and they all look at each other.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
And once somebody says something then they've
all got permission to say something and they
all can pretty much say to me as well how
they're feeling at that moment, they are connected.
Many of them will say they're tired, many
of them will say a little anxious, some of
them say that they're very happy, they're
starting to have some different feelings at
that point.
When I get to high school it gets a little
quieter, certainly when I get to colleges
and definitely work settings it gets quieter
and quieter.
People are less willing to express how they
feel or are becoming more and more disconnected
from how they feel.
Just as we've talked about in the nutrition
field for decades that Americans are disconnected
from the neck down, that when we walk by plate
glass windows we don't look at ourselves,
we have mirrors from the neck up, we don't
wanna know what we look like from the neck
down.
We are also encouraged by our society to disconnect
from the neck up.
You're too tired?
Take some caffeine.
You're sad?
Take a pill.
You're overworked?
Too bad, keep going.
You don't have time to exercise because it
makes you feel better?
Well you really better get to work and make
a dollar.
So we are being encouraged to ignore how we
feel, but how we feel is in fact what it's
all about.
And so I encourage you to look at my faces
up here [chuckles] and when I put this together
and this is stuff that I love, serendipity,
these are actually all up there alphabetically,
but you'll notice that all the ones in the
center are the happy ones.
Nobody wants to be on the outside team, everyone
wants to be on the inside and everyone wants
to be confident, happy, and optimistic.
And in fact what you eat has a huge impact
on whether you're on the inside or the outside,
whether you're feeling good, happy, optimistic,
confident, or you're feeling anger, anxiety,
not coping well, sad; what you eat plays a
profound role in how you feel.
So I love this, Will Rogers says, "You know
you've got to exercise your brain just like
your muscles."
And we talk about this and you have to feed
your brain just like you have to feed your
muscles.
These athletes no matter how well trained,
how genetically gifted, how well skilled and
drilled they are, if they can't get out of
bed in the morning because they're depressed
it doesn't matter how hard they've trained;
they can't get to the starting line let alone
the finish line.
And the beginning of The Good Mood Diet, actually
the kernel of the beginning of the thought
of The Good Mood Diet came from when I did
work with a very high profile, very elite
athlete who couldn't get out of bed in the
morning and was being paid a boat load of
money to show up.
So what I found at that time and what I've
continued to preach and work on in my practice
is that you must feed your brain.
That in fact if it was all about what we weighed,
which is what society tells us, everyone needs
to get on the scale and pay attention to what
you weigh, that the goal is weight loss, that
we all should weigh less and we all should
be thinking about weighing less.
If that's really what mattered to us in how
we felt, we would all be thin.
We know that diets work.
But we go on a diet, it makes us feel bad
and it doesn't matter if you've lost weight.
You go off of it.
So what The Good Mood Diet is, is the blending
of cutting edge sports nutrition, although
I kind of hide it in there because if I talk
too much about sports nutrition it would scare
everybody away, but nobody knows how to help
people alter their body composition, gain
muscle, lose fat like a sports nutritionist.
But blended with cutting edge neurobiology
of food is what I call it; the neuroscience
of food.
How food affects the health of the brain,
mood, cognitive function, our ability to rest
and relax, our ability to have the mental
energy and focus when we need it; when you
blend those it's a powerful force to make
you feel the difference.
So that when you follow this kind of concept
and then you go off of it, it's not about
what's happening with your weight that changes
you, because any of you who have tried to
lose weight know that it takes a long time
before you say, "Oh I really outta try and
lose this weight again."
What happens with The Good Mood Diet is that
within weeks you've realized that you feel
so bad you can't wait to be back on the diet.
And this is what I learned from clients and
from Good Mood Diet groups around the city
and the country as I did this.
So conceptually we think about feeding your
brain because most of us eat by default, you
can't eat this, you can't eat that, you can't
eat the next thing, don't eat, avoid, limit,
those are the language of the diet world.
And so whatever's left over is what ends up
on your plate which isn't very fun, it isn't
very inspirational, and it probably doesn't
taste very good either so nobody wants to
do that.
A typical weight loss diet is very low in
calories, it's so low in calories I always
say it wouldn't feed a small pigeon and in
fact the foods that you particularly are told
to avoid make those diets depressing.
Not depressing because, gee, you wish you
could eat other food, it's because in fact
they are biochemically depressing.
So let's talk about that.
I'm gonna do a little bit of a science course
here very quickly because I'm an educator
and a motivator and I know that when you reach
a certain point and you don't understand why
you're doing something you stop, but if you
understand why you keep going, you can make
the choice to keep going.
So did anybody ever play with a chemistry
set?
Yeah, and I almost burned down my parents'
basement with the chemistry set [laughs] at
one time in my life.
But think of your body as a chemistry set;
we are kind of this bag of chemicals.
And so food is the chemistry that enters our
body; our stomach is kinda that Erlenmeyer
flask and your metabolism is the Bunsen burner
underneath.
So when you eat the food goes into your stomach
and you shake it around and you have your
metabolic rate going and it ends up going
into your blood stream, digested, absorbed
into your blood stream.
What do you think the very first organ is
that's affected by the food that you eat?
Just yell it out.
>> female #1: The brain.
>>Dr. Susan Kleiner: The brain, right, see
I know I got a smart group here.
Most people say the liver, the heart, no the
brain.
In fact I want you to think about this because
it's so incredible: you don't even have to
even swallow the food for it to affect your
brain.
Think about when you get really hungry and
you haven't eaten maybe for hours, you put
something in your mouth and you're chewing
it and you just go, "Ah I feel so much better,
I'm eating."
Well it didn't even hit your stomach yet and
you're brain is affected by the fact that
you've put food in your mouth.
So imagine the power of eating the right foods,
the right combinations of foods at the right
times and the impact that those can have on
your brain.
So mechanisms of mood.
Well mood is very complex, it occurs in many,
by a sort of a synergy of changes in several
different parts of the brain and the neurotransmitters
are sort of the connectors, the chemicals
that connect and communicate from one brain
cell to the next; in fact from one cell in
the central nervous system to every other
cell in the central nervous system.
But we're talking about mood, what goes on
in the brain.
Serotonin, now there are a number of different
neurotransmitters, we're going to focus on
serotonin today because it is the most abundant
neurotransmitter that influences mood, it
is also probably one of the most well understood.
You know serotonin by anti-depressant drugs
today, they always are trying to raise serotonin
levels in the brain.
Shift to what is the building block of serotonin
in the brain?
Tryptophan.
Tryptophan is an amino acid, comes in from
protein, it is essential in the diet, we cannot
manufacture enough of it in the body, it is
the building block of serotonin in the brain;
it's found in the blood, the precursor to
serotonin.
Now we know that tryptophan is essential to
raise serotonin levels in the brain because
if we deplete the body from tryptophan then
serotonin levels drop.
And all this kind of connection is important
because what I talk about is evidence based,
meaning that it's scientifically supported;
the data are there for the information that
I'm giving you here today and what's written
in The Good Mood Diet.
[pause]
So if tryptophan is what is required to raise
serotonin levels in the brain, it is the building
block, then one would assume that a very high
protein diet should raise your mood.
In most instances diets that are very high
in protein and very low in carb do the opposite.
You wouldn't wanna work for anybody who was
on a very high protein low carb diet, you
wouldn't wanna be married to anybody that
was on that diet, you wouldn't wanna have
to partner with anybody at work on that diet
because it actually lowers serotonin levels
in most people.
People become angry, aggressive, depressed,
poor coping skills, all of those happen yet
we have an abundance of tryptophan.
Why?
[pause]
Well --
amazingly, and I always borrow a phrase, it's
the carbohydrates stupid, [chuckles] is what
you'll read in The Good Mood Diet because
in fact it is the carbohydrate in your diet
that allows tryptophan to cross the blood
brain barrier and enter the brain.
Now you know this, you know this in your gut,
you know this fundamentally.
What ingredient, what single food makes you
feel really good really fast?
>>male #1: Sugar.
[pause]
Sugar, right.
So don't ever let anybody tell you that sugar
doesn't make you feel good.
Now we're gonna talk about why too much sugar
is on my Feel-Bad Foods list, but understand
the science and why in the short term sugar
makes you feel so good.
Now you know it's very simple, it's very rapidly
digested and enters the blood stream.
When carbohydrate levels go up, when blood
sugar goes up, insulin, the hormone that helps
take blood sugar out of the blood and transfer
it into the muscles or to the liver, when
insulin goes up as well, it stimulates a whole
separate cascade of biochemical events that
actually take out all the other competing
amino acids in the blood stream that compete
with tryptophan to cross the blood brain barrier
and they leave tryptophan out there all alone.
There are seven other amino acids that resemble
tryptophan.
Those seven other amino acids compete for
the same receptor molecule, the same usher
that takes tryptophan into the brain.
And so when you have a very high protein diet
you have a lot of those competitive amino
acids around and those compete with tryptophan
and so a proportionately lower amount of tryptophan
gets into the brain.
If, on the other hand, you could remove those
competitive amino acids, which is what happens
when you eat carbohydrate and amazingly it
takes those amino acids and shuttles them
to the muscle cell where we want the muscle
to recover, repair, and grow after exercise,
since we're all active.
It leaves tryptophan out there with little
competition to enter into the brain and raise
serotonin levels; this happens in an infinitesimal,
small amount of time.
And so the sugar that you eat raises of course
not only serotonin, there are number of other
neurotransmitters that are raised as well
that are too much for me to go into today.
But when it comes to raising mood, carbohydrate
plays an enormously important role; so important
that diets that are lower than 40 percent
of calories as carbohydrate have been shown
to be depressing, literally depressing.
So ideally we should eat carbohydrate and
protein together; it is the ideal fuel and
recovery combination for muscles, it is also
a beautiful combination for the brain, giving
you the tryptophan that you need and enhancing
the movement of tryptophan into the brain
to raise serotonin levels.
Well so I said sugar makes you feel good.
Well then why do we keep telling people to
stop eating so much sugar?
Well this is why, and we've had a discussion
sort of nationally about insulin resistance.
That's something that if you have a lot of
sugar over a long period of time and you start
to gain weight, can happen.
So over a long period of time you can develop
insulin resistance and move slowly into the
beginning of Type II diabetes.
However, that's long way off.
What also happens when you eat a lot of sugar
frequently is that it is considered a stress
by the body.
When your blood sugar levels rapidly rise
insulin meets it and lowers it and rises again
and lowers it; your body responds with a stress
response to that.
One of the results of the stress hormone response
is protein degradation, breaking down proteins.
This is kind of part of that fight or flight
response, we're talking about a very short
term, acute response to a stress.
And so if you begin to degrade proteins you
are flooding your bloodstream once again with
lots and lots of protein and lowering the
serotonin level.
There you have to go back and eat more sugar
to then help move the tryptophan into the
brain and so you get on, in a very short period
of time, within four to five days, maximum
seven days, your body will begin using other
neurotransmitters as well to force a craving
for more and more sugar so that you can raise
the serotonin levels over and over again.
So in addition to the long term stress that
lots of sugar puts on your body this is a
very acute short term stress and it's why
you begin on a daily basis to want more and
more sugar because you want to raise your
mood.
It's a biological function, a biological urge.
This is not about do you have the willpower,
this is about making the choices that alter
your physiological responses.
So we go back to the foods that were served
in the cafeteria today; slow digesting, whole
carbohydrate, sources rich in carbohydrate.
So of course whole grains, fruits, vegetables,
beans, those are all wonderful sources of
slowly digesting carbohydrates that keep you
even all day long, keep your blood sugar levels
even.
[pause]
What types of proteins?
There are lots of different proteins, they
are mostly all absolutely wonderful.
I have some favorites.
Now fish is on here obviously for the fish
oil that we will get to in a moment, but there's
new data on fish protein in and of itself
showing that fish protein may help the body,
we call it, mobilize the fat stores in the
abdomen.
Meaning that no you can't spot reduce by eating
loads of fish, but that fish protein can enhance,
the fat cells in our abdomen can be different
than some of the fat cells in the rest of
the body, and so if you can help turn those
on and get them more active, which is what
fish protein has been shown to do, along with
the fish oils, then you can hopefully reduce
this midsection that increases the risk of
disease over the years.
So that is a great benefit of fish and we
will talk about the fish oils in a moment.
You're gonna see milk up there.
I am a very big advocate of milk and this
is why: milk is an ideal good mood food; it's
carbohydrate and protein together.
The protein in milk is high in tryptophan,
the protein in milk is also high in an amino
acid, leucine, that is the trigger for protein
metabolism so after you exercise you enhance
your recovery.
And as I said it has the natural carbohydrate
lactose in there.
It also has Vitamin D which is required for
the manufacture of serotonin.
So there's a natural combination of nutrients
in milk that is a true good mood food.
Eggs.
Well we're gonna talk about the yolk and it's
there and that'll be in the next section on
fats, but of course egg protein is an ideal
protein highly biologically available.
Now turkey most people nod their head and
they say, "Yeah I've heard turkey's high in
tryptophan and I know that at Thanksgiving
I get really sleepy after my Thanksgiving
meal.
It must be from that tryptophan."
And I say, "Oh it was probably the 2,000 calories
and five glasses of wine that you had --
[laughter]
[chuckles] at your Thanksgiving meal [laughs]
not necessarily the tryptophan, but yes turkey
is high in tryptophan."
And I said, "Does it make you sleepy in the
evening?"
Well in fact we have 16 different receptor
molecules in the brain that recognize serotonin
and so those turn on and off on the light/dark
cycle.
So based on Circadian rhythms during the day
serotonin makes you feel alert, awake, you're
calm but sort of alive and ready to go and
keeps your mood elevated.
When it gets dark outside in the evening serotonin
helps your body quiet down, relax, and get
ready for rest.
And so you can make use of that, you can what
I say put your food to work for you.
If you have dairy or milk in the evening you
can help turn on that relaxation cycle.
Now if I said to you, "Have a glass of milk
in the evening," most people would add –
>>male #2: Cookies.
>>Dr. Susan Kleiner: [chuckles] cookies right.
So I like to just add the chocolate or the
cocoa powder right to the milk, heat it up,
and there's nothin' wrong with having a little
bit of cocoa powder it makes everything taste
better.
And so a hot cocoa in the evening is actually
part of the Good Mood plan, helping you rest
and get ready for bed in the evening.
Fat.
We have had a horrible fat phobia in this
country and what we are learning is turning
nutrition advice on its head.
[pause]
Not only are diets that are lower than 25
percent of calories depressing, lower than
25 percent of calories from fat are in the
diet we have a lowered ability to cope with
stress and increased incidents of anxiety
and anger.
So when I'm out on the road I wish I had some
kinda avocado or somethin' to hand out to
people [chuckles] while I'm drivin' around
on Seattle roads 'cause people are pretty
angry and aren't coping very well with stress.
But one of the things that you can do is begin
to enjoy the high performance fats that we
must have in our diets.
The data is now showing that these fats are
so critically important, including fish oil,
they are so critically important to the health
of the brain and the brain cell that if you
do not have adequate fats in the diet the
brain will slow down fat metabolism, meaning
you will not burn optimum amounts of fats
in the body.
So if you are on a very low fat diet and you're
trying to lose weight you won't lose the fat
that you can.
And if you are on a diet restricted in calories
you may lose more lean tissue than you want
rather than preferentially burning the fat.
With the goal of raising the whole amount
of fat that's available proportionately for
the brain cell membrane and the entire central
nervous system that is lined with fat, the
brain will turn off fat burning.
So high performance fats.
[pause]
Certainly avocados, olive oil, nuts, seeds.
When we talk about extra virgin olive oil
one of the great benefits of extra virgin
olive oil is that it contains a compound that's
identical to ibuprofen.
When you get that peppery finish that makes
you kind of go [ ] if you ever dip in extra
virgin olive oil itself, that compound that
gives you that little burning sensation, that
peppery finish, is actually a very powerful
anti-inflammatory.
And so extra virgin olive oil is special compared
to all the different olive oils.
Fish oil.
Fish oil is unique, flax seed oil, hemp seed,
none of those replace the two compounds found
in fish oil or marine oils, DHA and EPA those
are required in the brain.
ALA, the third Omega fat which is a great
anti-inflammatory found in much of the plant
kingdom is not a substitute no matter what
you've been told.
On the best day with the best genetic possibilities
when you've eaten the best diet, a maximum
of five to maybe ten percent of that ALA will
be converted to DHA or EPA.
So the body just does not have the capacity
to replace it.
DHA is absolutely essential to the function
of a brain cell; it is what keeps the inflammatory
processes in the brain cell in check.
Inflammation and oxidation are a side effect
of being alive; we all have it going on.
In the brain and in the body we have systems
to help fight this all the time.
The system that is critical in the brain depends
on the Omega-3 fat DHA.
[pause]
Because fat is so essential to the mass of
the brain, 60 percent of the mass of the brain
is fat, so you must have fat in your diet.
Because the composition of a brain cell membrane
so depends on DHA and on fat, if DHA isn't
around it will replace DHA with another fat;
that fat can function structurally but it
is not a functional anti-inflammatory compound
so that inflammation proceeds unchecked.
When we have low levels of DHA in the body
brain cells become, neuroscientists call it
rigid or not plastic.
We wanna have fluidity in our cells and when
inflammation proceeds in the brain we lose
that fluidity of those cells, communication
slows down, neurotransmitters and electrical
impulses cannot move smoothly, cognitive function
is lower, memory is decreased, mood is lowered.
People who have low levels of DHA in their
diet, people who are low fish eaters, have
a significantly increased risk of depression,
not to mention all the other degenerative
diseases of the brain, and many other certainly
heart disease and other diseases in the body.
We are finding that these compounds are critically
important.
If you don't supplement with anything, you
must supplement with DHA and EPA.
If don't want to supplement and you love fish,
five fish meals a week will get you to the
amount of recommended fish oil at this point
which is about 1,000 milligrams total every
day.
So this is critically important.
Now fish oil has also been shown to enhance
weight loss; again you're getting the brain
in a more healthy foundational situation so
that it will allow for fat metabolism to proceed
in the body.
Eggs.
Who's throwin' their egg yolks down the drain?
[pause]
One, two –
[laughter]
I know there's a lot more of you or you're
not eating eggs at all.
I want you to know there has never been a
study, never been a study, that showed that
an egg yolk a day raises cholesterol levels
in healthy people, never been a study.
And now we have four studies that have shown
that an egg yolk a day does not raise cholesterol
levels in healthy people.
And I would take the big step and say you
could probably make it two egg yolks a day
in a healthy person, but it also depends on
what else you're eating in your diet.
Now The Good Mood Diet with an egg yolk a
day stays within the American Heart Association
guidelines of 300 milligrams of cholesterol,
dietary cholesterol a day.
Why am I telling you to eat egg yolks?
Well once we get this whole Vitamin D thing
straightened out, Vitamin D right now if you
haven't heard of it you're not Googling [laughs]
because it's everywhere and particularly here
in the Northwest it is a problem.
We have low Vitamin D nutriture, we don't
get much sunshine, and low Vitamin D intake
is highly associated with numerous issues
including depression, by the way.
Once we get that taken care of the next nutrient
coming down the pike is choline.
Choline is a B vitamin, it is half of the
most abundant neurotransmitter in the body,
acetylcholine, responsible for every thought
and every movement that we have.
[pause]
In the United States ever since we started
dumping egg yolks down the drain we consume
somewhere around 30 percent of our requirement
for choline.
It is dramatic, there is now numerous studies
on choline, there are studies looking not
only at total health but certainly at brain
function.
The National Institutes of Mental Health are
supplementing people with degenerative diseases
of the brain with two phospholipids found
in egg yolks: phosphatidylcholine and phosphatidylserine
and have shown a slowing of the rate of progression
of Parkinson's disease and Alzheimer's disease.
And studies in 18 year old boys starting college
have shown enhanced memory when they were
supplemented.
So we're at both ends of the spectrum with
this, it is a huge problem.
If you eat just an egg yolk a day you get
about half of your choline need for the day.
And then we find choline in other foods as
well.
So it is very important if you are not allergic
to eggs you should be eating an egg yolk a
day.
An easy way is to boil 'em up at the beginning
of the week and just pop a hard boiled egg
in your mouth everyday whatever you do, and
you will find that now you've got another
great easy source of protein.
And so add that egg to breakfast and enjoy
it because we have cut out a foundational
food in our diets.
[pause]
So I want you to think about what you need
to eat, not what you can't eat next.
Okay, I'm gonna say that again.
Think about what you need to eat, not what
you can't eat next.
Americans focus on what they can't eat; it
is so depressing [chuckles].
Food is such an intimate part of our lives,
we should be looking forward to eating.
We share it with friends, we share it with
our lovers, we share it with our families,
we share it at work, it is a primitive part
of our psyche to share food and break bread
with another person.
And so when we are more concerned when we're
at a party of fighting with the brownie on
the table than we are with talking to the
cute guy or girl next to you, that's a real
problem, you're missing out on life, you're
limiting your horizons.
Focus on what you need to eat, not what you
can't eat next.
Now I have a great story to tell you with
Matt Hasselbeck's permission.
I worked with him a number of years ago when
he was getting injured a lot and he needed
to pack on some pounds.
And so this is just an illustration of how
if we crave foods, if we don't feed ourselves
well, our brain will force us to eat certain
things that cravings and desires and what
feel like uncontrollable urges with food often
can be purely physiological drives that can
be altered if you change the way you eat.
Matt was known as the ice cream boy in the
Seahawks training facility.
When I walked in the first day to work with
him all the guys were snickering.
And I walked in and I thought, "God is my
fly down, I mean why is everybody laughin'?"
I get down and I sit down with he and his
lovely wife and I said, "What's gonna on?
Why was everybody laughing when I walked in?"
"Oh," he said, "they've all taken bets on
me workin' with you and who's gonna win the
dietician or me."
I said, "Why?"
"Well," he says, "let me tell you what I eat."
So he told me what he ate during the day and
then when he got home in the evening he'd
eat about a quart or more of Haagen-Dazs.
And when he would get on the plane to go to
an away game, on the plane for the return
he would have five or six Dove bars.
[laughter]
So was this an outta control athlete just
taking advantage of the position that he was
in and how active he was or was this some
fundamental physiological need for ice cream?
Well after I talked with Matt he told me that
during the day he ate around 1,500 calories
worth of food and he trained at least three
times during the day, sometimes four, he'd
do his morning workout, his strength program
in the training room, they had the team training
at some point in the morning, he'd have quarterback
skills and drills, they'd train again in the
afternoon and so by the time he'd get home
he said, "About 1,500 calories."
Well the guy needed 5,000 calories a day just
to maintain his weight.
So when he got home he was starving.
What did the brain say?
"Immediate fuel.
I need structural component, I need to raise
my mood, and I need fuel, sugar and fat."
What better thing than ice cream?
So I put together a program for Matt that
gave him around 3,000, 3,500 calories during
the day, much of that in liquid nutrition
using smoothies and if you ever see my book
Power Eating it is packed with recovery drinks
and smoothies; it is a very important part
of an active person's life whether or not
you're burnin' 5,000 calories a day or 1,600
calories a day we are runnin' around a lot
and liquid smoothie packed nutrition is a
great convenience.
So for Matt he had between food and smoothies
around 3,500 calories a day.
When he got home he had a really nice dinner
and of course I still had about I don't know
cup and a half of ice cream in his diet.
And people say to me, "You kept ice cream
in it?"
Well yeah I mean he could eat 5,000 calories
a day and if I gave the guy who was eatin'
that much ice cream a diet with no ice cream
he'd say, "Hey, doc you're a nice lady but
I'm not gonna follow this diet."
Right?
[chuckles] So we kept the ice cream in there
in the evening.
After about a week, 10 days, Matt called and
he said, "Hey doc, is there a healthier snack
I could eat at night.
I don't even want that ice cream anymore."
So with all the permission in the world his
body was well fed, his brain was well fed,
he didn't want that anymore.
It's such a great illustration of how potent
food is in the choices that you make.
So that if today say you had your lunch and
at lunch you ate all these great good mood
foods and then you went and you I don't know
the chocolate chip cookies are your absolute
favorite, there is nothing as good as those
chocolate chip cookies, and you had a couple
chocolate chip cookies for dessert and while
you're sitting here you've been beatin' yourself
up about eating those chocolate chip cookies.
And so you go, "You know what I ate those
chocolate chip cookies," and you go back to
your desk and it gets to be around I don't
know four o'clock and you're startin' to get
hungry and you go, "Nope, no snack because
I ate those chocolate chip cookies."
And then you get home and it's dinner time
and you say, "Well I'm pretty hungry but oh
I can only eat a salad because I ate those
chocolate chip cookies."
And then as it gets on toward the evening
you're getting really hungry and, "I shouldn't
eat anything," and you're gettin' really anxious
and really stressed and now anything that
doesn't run across the counter is fair game.
[laughter]
Right?
So now if there's chocolate chip cookies or
there's chocolate cake, who knows what is
in the house, you're eating that and half
a dozen other things as well.
Now you really feel bad and you go to sleep
and you don't sleep well and you wake up in
the morning and you say, "Oh God I can't eat
breakfast now, I ate all that at night and
everything that Dr. Kleiner said, the heck
with it.
I feel so bad I'm not, I can't follow anything,
I'm just a loser."
Well if you had eaten those chocolate chip
cookies and you just loved 'em and you came
in and you heard me speak and I say to you,
"No you've really gotta eat every two and
a half to three hours because physiologically
you're blood sugar drops whether you eat tofu
or a chocolate chip cookie you're gonna get
hungry.
So plan what you need to eat in two and a
half to three hours."
And so you go back and you go, "Oh yeah, well
a good snack let's see protein.
I can have some nuts, that has healthy fat
and some protein, and I can have a piece of
fruit, that's a really good carb, or I can
have a piece of cheese, that's a great combination.
And now I have energy to finish my day and
go workout."
And you get home and you feel great and you
eat your healthy dinner and then you have
your hot cocoa in the evening or if it's kinda
hot out, if we don't have air conditioning
we're gonna have cold milk, cold chocolate
milk.
And you sleep really well and you go to sleep
and you wake up and all of a sudden you've
slept so well, you woke up an hour earlier,
maybe you can go for a walk.
And you come into work and you're on your
way.
And so think like an athlete, don't rewind
the tape over and over and over again.
It is paralyzing.
No matter how many times you rewind that tape
about having eaten those chocolate chip cookies
you will never not have eaten those cookies
even though we're really hoping that one time
we won't have eaten it, it's never gonna happen.
So forget the past, it doesn't matter what
you ate a moment ago, it is absolutely irrelevant.
Think about what you need to eat, whatever
you ate you ate, I hope you enjoyed it, it
should have been wonderful, it should have
just delighted you.
Now think about what you need to eat next;
a snack, a meal, a hot cocoa, whatever it
is that's how you stay on the good mood food
highway.
[pause]
So there is a list of Feel-Great Foods in
the book and that's because all publishers
want something that magazine editors will
stick in a magazine, and so I had to have
a list.
[chuckles] You have to have lists, you will
see every diet book has lists because that's
what gets into the magazines.
In fact we could fill this room with every
food in the world, they all make us feel good,
but some foods make us feel better than other
foods in fact, and some foods when we eat
them too frequently as I said with sugar,
can make us feel bad.
There's a special group of foods, Anti-inflammatory
Foods, and this is worked fundamentally into
the diet, this list is not in the book, but
all the foods that are promoted and we talk
about fundamentally this is a big goal when
you eat is to eat these foods rich in color
and high performance fats, all of these herbs,
are great sources to help reduce inflammation
in the body.
And then the Feel-Bad foods.
Well it's a short list fortunately, but they
can take up a lot of our diet.
Alcohol, need I say more, it's a central nervous
system depressant.
[chuckles] So, you know, in a small amount
it can fit into The Good Mood Diet but don't
let anybody tell you that it's a health beverage.
[laughter]
The alcohol companies, the wine companies,
I kind of feel like the U.S.
Government may be in cahoots with them as
well, really promoting the use of alcohol
as a way to get healthy.
In a country that is two-thirds overweight
and more than a third obese at this point,
this is a horribly irresponsible stance to
take, not to mention the abuse of alcohol.
But the addition of these calories, the slowing
of the metabolic rate, the influence that
it has on your physical performance for many
days afterwards, it is not a sharp tool to
add to your diet.
If you feel that you are stressed think about
the other things that you could add to your
diet before adding alcohol.
Now you will see in a moment how it fits into
the diet, but remember it will slow your metabolism,
it will slow your cognitive function.
For every, if you have three to five drinks,
depending on your size, it takes 72 hours
to return to full physical performance.
72 hours, this is from the University of Notre
Dame.
So be aware of what drinking will do.
Caffeine, now caffeine opposite from alcohol,
is a stimulant.
We know it wakes us up, it makes us alert,
it makes us feel pretty good, it's a performance
enhancer.
It lowers our rate of perceived exertion,
meaning that when you have a little caffeine
before you workout you don't perceive that
you're training as hard as you are so you'll
push a little harder so you get a better training
effect, so it will enhance performance.
There's a prudent use of caffeine prior to
exercise if you are a caffeine user.
Obviously I don't want you to start using
caffeine.
Be aware that you're gonna, you hear a lot
of hype about energy drinks; know that a Red
Bull, now I'm not promoting it I just want
people to be informed.
Yes we are down the road from Starbucks headquarters,
but a tall latte has three times the amount
of caffeine as a Red Bull.
So just be an informed consumer.
There's a lot of bashing going on right now
and there's a lot of good reason for it and
there's a lot of things in energy drinks that
are worse than what we're drinkin' in coffee
and coffee has a great anti-inflammatory effect,
an anti-oxidant effect.
We can go on and on, but if caffeine is your
issue that you're focusing on be informed.
And I don't feel that coffee should be let
off the hook when we are talkin' about the
amount of caffeine in energy drinks.
Caffeine in large doses can give you a rebound
effect and you know this, everyone has gone
through this at some point unless they really
are not a caffeine user.
And that is it makes you feel really great
when you have one cup and then two and three
and four and then you start to feel bad.
And in the afternoon when you're using caffeine
to keep you aware and alert rather than The
Good Mood Diet or gettin' out and goin' for
a little walk or drinking some water because
you're probably somewhat dehydrated, the caffeine
makes you feel worse and worse and worse;
lowers your focus, decreases your attention
time.
So be very aware of that.
Fried foods, fatty meats, fatty snack foods,
those are promoting inflammation in the body
and our goal is to reduce the inflammation.
Just like I talked about in the brain it's
goin' on in the whole body.
Fundamentally all of these foods promote inflammation
and heart disease, cancer, etcetera.
And so if you have a lot of inflammation in
the body you don't feel good.
And refined sugars and starches we really
already talked about.
So very briefly and I'm not gonna spend much
time on this 'cause I wanna give a little
bit of time for questions, is that the diet
does have a strategy and there's two weeks
of menus in there.
The first two weeks we call the Good Mood
Accelerator.
I ask ya give me two weeks.
You can practically hold your breath for two
weeks; two weeks is a really short period
of time.
You could probably not leave the building
here at Google for two weeks and not really
notice it.
[laughs] So give me two weeks and really clean
yourself out; eliminate the Feel-Bad Foods.
[pause]
If you want to lose weight it is an outcome
of The Good Mood Diet, it is not the goal.
In fact weight loss is a long term goal of
changing short little habits: drinking more
water, starting to get exercise, eating more
greens, doing all the little things where
on a daily basis you can look back and pat
yourself on the back and be successful.
Weight loss takes so long that we don't feel
successful, we feel like a failure and so
you stop doing all these other things that
have on a daily basis a true impact on your
health and performance.
And so those are the goals.
When you do all of those things right if you
need to lose weight, you will.
In fact my clients know when they come to
me that when they get everything right the
first week, when they finally are doing their
real regular workout, they're hydrating the
way they're supposed to, they're eating everything
they need to eat, at the end of the week they
gain weight.
[pause]
So don't look at the scale.
Those are long term outcomes.
Now over time using a scale can be useful
and helpful for monitoring what's going on
with us.
Think about how you feel, get very connected
with the food that you eat.
And then after the first phase you can add
these kind of fun little foods, whoops, fun
little foods back but you don't have to; there's
no requirement to doing it.
And I talk about knowing the added sugar in
your diet; be aware of where sugar is added
to your diet.
When you pick up a box of Shredded Wheat and
you look at the nutrition label there's no
sugar, it says zero sugar; wheat doesn't contain
sugar, grains don't contain sugar.
So any box that you pick up that's cereal
that has sugar in it means that it was added
by the manufacturer and don't think it's from
the two slices of little strawberries that
they put in there; there's like two strawberries
in a whole box.
So it's sugar added.
Be informed.
Milk, an eight ounce, and I have a whole section
of this in the book, an eight ounce cup of
milk contains 12 grams of sugar, naturally
lactose, the natural carbohydrate in milk.
Look at carton of yogurt it will have, if
you take plain yogurt it will be slightly
higher because the fluid has been taken out,
the solids are more concentrated, you have
13 grams of sugar in a plain carton of yogurt.
A flavored carton of yogurt, using sugar,
typically has a minimum of 26 grams, 30 grams.
You can start to figure out where the added
sugar is in your diet by reading the labels.
Every four grams of sugar is a teaspoon.
[pause]
So I have, if you guys can come up with something
less dogmatic sounding than the 10 Commandments
I would love it, but so far I haven't, email
me if you come up with something better, but
these are the 10 Commandments and they are
a great guideline.
First and foremost it is all about how you
feel, think about what you need to eat, not
what you can't eat.
Next, always combine starches with protein
and/or healthy fat.
Around exercise we leave the fat out or to
a very small minimum because it slows digestion;
you don't wanna slow digestion around exercise.
Nourish yourself before and after exercise,
and every 2 1/2 to 3 hours all day long.
I love dairy three times, morning when you
wake up, after exercise 'cause it is such
a potent recovery beverage both for hydration
and muscle and mental performance, and in
the evening when you wanna rest.
An egg yolk I say or soy every day.
Whole soy contains lecithin which also contains,
which has the choline in it.
Nuts every day.
Fish five times a week.
Of course hydration plays an enormous role
here; five to six cups of water every day
in addition to all of your beverages, and
that is a science based number and we can
talk about where that comes from at another
time; may be in the book.
Of course a variety of fruits and vegetables;
this is foundational, fundamental.
Don't just eat carrots and apples --
[pause]
and bananas; that's what Americans eat, carrots,
apples, and bananas.
Spread out [chuckles], try something new.
It is peach season in Washington State.
The peaches, half a peach is like the size
of a whole peach, they're each a pound I think,
they are fabulous, you can eat them raw, you
can throw them in a smoothie, you can put
them in your yogurt, you can make a pie, you
can bake a peach, you can grill a peach, you
can broil a peach.
Enjoy the stone fruit this time of year.
And of course I'd be lying to you if I said
that it was all about diet.
Diet creates the foundation in your body and
your mind so that you can have the energy
physically and mentally to do the other things
in life that are so important to making a
full rounded, happy life.
And so exercise, rest, relationships, creativity,
and spirituality.
And in fact it takes action to have satisfaction.
Physiologically you must move to have a sense
of satisfaction.
So that is neurochemistry of the brain tied
to the movement of the body.